60 minutes conversation with former
White House chief strategist Steve
Bannon is his first extensive television
interview since he left the
administration in February Time magazine
put him on the cover with the headline
the great manipulator the founding board
member the conservative publication
Breitbart news was a key player in
president Trump's White House he left
last month after clashes with other
aides Bannon then returned to Breitbart
we talked to him about how he views
himself and his continuing mission to
stand up for the president so how do you
want to be perceived you today because
you have a media image many others I
think is pretty accurate I'm a street
fighter that's what I am you're more
than that no I think I'm I think I'm a
street fighter there by the way I think
that's why Donald Trump and I get along
so well Donald Trump's a fighter great
counter puncher great counter puncher
he's a fighter I'm gonna be his wingman
outside for the entire time they're
pretending not to be attacking Donald
Trump our purpose is to support doctrine
by the way and destroy his enemies to
make sure his enemies know that there's
no free shot on goal by the way after
the Charlottesville situation I felt old
General Kelly I was the only guy that
came out and tried to defend him I was
the only guy that said he's talking
about something taking it up to a higher
level where did this all go where does
this end as the end and does it end and
taking down the Washington Monument does
his end and taking down I'll tell you
where many people suggest it should have
gone it should have gone in terms of
denouncing specifically from the very
beginning neo-nazis and white
supremacists and people of that
political view and he should have gone
there because those were people that
Americans in World War two went to fight
against and it should have instantly
have denounced them and you didn't at
first instinct in fact you seemed to be
doubling down in terms of a moral
equivalency what he was trying to say is
that people that support the monument
staying there peacefully and people that
oppose that that's the normal course of
First Amendment but he's talking about
the neo-nazis and neo Confederates in
the Klan who by the way are absolutely
awful there's no room in American
politics for that there's no room in
American society for that in all Donald
Trump was saying is where is it in does
it end in taking down the Washington
Monument
to end and taking down my Rushmore is
that in and taking Churchill's bust out
of the Oval Office my problem my problem
and I told general Kelly this when you
side with a man you side with him I was
proud to come out and try to defend
President Trump in the media that there
no exceptions
in terms of siding with someone you can
tell him hey maybe you could do it a
better way but if you're gonna break
then resign if you're going to break
with him resign the stuff that was
leaked at that week by certain members
of the White House I thought was
unacceptable if you find it unacceptable
you should resign though who are you
talking about I'm talking about
obviously about Gary Cohen and some
other people that if you don't like what
he's doing and you don't agree with it
you have an obligation to resign so Gary
told Gary Cohn should have resigned
absolutely there you go he's not afraid
to call people out charlie and it sounds
like he still has a good relationship
with President Trump he does they've
talked a number of times but I'm in here
he didn't talk much about the infighting
within the White House which we've heard
lots of reports about Gary Cohen is one
of those people he calls a globalist now
he calls himself a populist and those
are forces that he thinks are going to
continue to clash I mean his mission his
economic nationalism and he thinks that
populism like it was with brexit is the
ought to be the wave of the future it
also wants to go to economic war with
China and he talks about that a lot as
well they know North Korea he says
there's no nuclear there's no military
option in that he agrees with a lot of
other I think it's interesting though
what he said about Gary Cohn some people
say it's good to have people that don't
always agree with you so you can hear
other points of view but the interesting
too is he clearly here's a guy who many
people have classified with things that
he doesn't think fair to him denounce
all these groups and saying they should
be denounced there's no place for them
but that's what everybody should have
said at first glance yeah where did you
do the interview at his home in
Washington you can see the full reports
Sunday on 60 minutes that's at 7 6
central right here on CBS